>> Dana: A NEW JERSEY MAN
CHARGED WITH MAKING TERRORISTIC
THREATS AFTER INTENTIONALLY
COUGHING ON A GROCERY STORE
WORKER WHILE CLAIMING HE HAD A
CORONAVIRUS.
LET’S BRING IN JUDGE NAPOLITANO.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WROTE THIS MEMO YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE CORONAVIRUS APPEARS TO
MEET THE STATUTORY DEFINITION OF
A BIOLOGICAL AGENT, SUCH AS ACTS
THAT COULD IMPLICATE THE NATIONS
STATUTE OR ATTENDANT THE ATTEMPT
TO USE COVID-19 AS A WEAPON
AGAINST AMERICANS WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS,
JUDGE, DO YOU THINK SOMEONE
COULD BE CHARGED WITH TERRORISM
FOR COUGHING ON SOMEBODY AND
SAYING THEY HAVE CORONAVIRUS
EVEN IF THEY DON’T?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU BOTH SIDES OF
THE ARGUMENT.
THIS INSTANCE TO WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING OCCURRED IN A WEGMANS
SUPERMARKET, DOWN ON THE
NEW JERSEY SHORE WHICH OUTRAGED
GOVERNOR MURPHY.
THE INCIDENT CONSISTED OF SOME
SORT OF A DISPUTE BETWEEN THE
CUSTOMER AND THE CASHIER.
THE CUSTOMER COUGHED ON THE
CASHIER AND SAID BY THE WAY, I
HAVE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT WAS REPORTED AND HE WAS
ARRESTED.
IN ORDINARY TIMES HE WOULD BE
CHARGED WITH A SIMPLE ASSAULT
MEANING HE DIDN’T BREAK THE SKIN
OR BREAK HER BONES BUT IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY TERRIFIED ABOUT
CONTRACTING THIS DISEASE, IT’S
UNHEARD OF TO THINK THAT SOMEONE
WOULD INTENTIONALLY GIVE IT TO
YOU.
SO DID HE INTENTIONALLY CAUSE A
BIOLOGICAL AGENT TO INFECT
SOMEONE ELSE?
WE DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
YET BECAUSE WE DON’T KNOW IF HE
IS POSITIVE AND IF HE WASN’T
THEN PRESUMABLY THE CASHIER IS
NOT.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE
GOVERNMENT’S ARGUMENT IS, THE
ANTITERRORIST STATUTES HAVE A
COUPLE OF REQUIREMENTS AND
THERE.
THEY REQUIRE TWO OR MORE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE INTENDED TO ALTER THE
FOREIGN POLICY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
NOW, WHO KNOWS WHAT THIS GUY WAS
THINKING BUT IT’S QUITE A LEAP
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO PROVE
THAT.
THEY WOULD BE BETTER OFF
CHARGING HIM, LOCKING HIM UP
BECAUSE THE COURTS ARE CLOSED IN
NEW JERSEY.
I DON’T KNOW HOW LONG HE WOULD
BE LOCKED UP BEFORE HE EVEN SEES
THE JUDGE, THEN CHARGE HIM WITH
SIMPLE ASSAULT AND WAIT AND SEE
WHAT THE TESTS SHOW.
>> Dana: IS IT SIMILAR TO
PULLING THE FIRE ALARM IN A
CROWDED THEATER?
>> WELL WHAT HE SAID CAUSED AN
ENORMOUS DISTURBANCE AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
IT GOT THE ATTENTION OF THE
GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR MURPHY
HIMSELF.
NOT A LAWYER BUT THE CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN THE
STATE DIRECTED THAT HE BE
CHARGED UNDER NEW JERSEY’S
ANTI-TERROR LAW WHICH MIMICS THE
LANGUAGE OF THE FEDERAL LAW,
WHICH ALSO REQUIRES TWO OR MORE
ACTS OF VIOLENCE INTENDING TO
AFFECT THE FOREIGN POLICY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT DOING SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN
A PUBLIC PLACE CAN CAUSE
TREMENDOUS PANDEMONIUM AND HE
WOULD BE LIABLE FOR INJURIES
THAT OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMONIUM.
LIKE A STAMPEDE FROM PEOPLE WHO
WATCHED AND HEARD WHAT HE DID TO
THIS CASHIER.
>> Dana: UP BY THE WAY, DON’T
DO IT.
>> OF COURSE DON’T DO IT.
BUT THESE CRISES THESE TRAGEDIES
THAT WE ARE LIVING THROUGH NOW
OFTEN CAUSE NOVEL LITIGATION.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
THERE’S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
MANY MORE.
I DON’T THINK ANYONE WILL GET
CLASSIC COMIC PROSECUTED UNTIL
THE CRISIS HAS PASSED AND THERE
IS A GENERAL AGREEMENT ABOUT HOW
TO TREAT THE CASES.